Good morning John. So, I'm watching a scary thing happen
Not just in my country, but with my peers and my friends, this fairly new, I think, sense that
all expertise is false
that you can't trust the government or the media or scientists or even charities everything is fake
We get a dozen questions a week on Dear
Hank and John from people who start out saying:
"Look I know that I have to get to the bottom of every single story myself because of course you can't trust anyone anymore."
If that has become the case we are absolutely screwed. No one can get to the bottom of everything,
in fact that's what experts are for.
Journalists and international organizations and scientists and the government these are experts that have been tasked by
society with getting to the bottom of different kinds of things
and there are all groups that more and more it seems we feel we cannot trust.
What can we trust then? Well mostly whatever narrative we've already signed up for. If things fit into it
we shout them around and if they don't we quietly ignore them. The causes of this are plentiful
It's human nature, it's the result of a fractured system of information sharing government has of course and almost traditionally
deteriorated its own credibility by focusing more on winning than governing
and news media has destroyed its own credibility and also everyone else's by
focusing on cheap easy things that people to gobble up like candy,
mainly opinion pieces and shouting matches between people who are paid to disagree with each other.
This is at least in part because the financial model that supported journalism
as well as the editorial control that newspapers once had over what people saw first
simultaneously fell apart and when we're on the internet. We very rarely look at a front page
we mostly look at what's on our feed and what goes into a feed isn't controlled by experts
It's often controlled by our worst instincts. It turns out when the hive mine decides
what's on the front page it becomes drama and opinion and controversy and demonization of the other and self-congratulation
and thus the hot takes have gotten so hot I'm worried the whole country's going to catch fire.
And if you actually pick up a physical newspaper or magazine like none of that's the news.
On the front page of an actual mainstream newspaper or
inside of a magazine like the economist what you find is
valuable,
expensive,
expert driven,
truth-telling
Like who knew.
I'd had forgotten.
Important things about Venezuela
or Yemen or why Americans are dying younger. If you read
peer-reviewed articles. If you find a politician who will actually talk with you.
If you find a news source that is mainstream and actually read the news that's there
By and large you find that
experts are actually
experts
Look sometimes reporting is bad or
incomplete or inflammatory.
But if the Wall Street Journal publishes a piece that isn't good reporting, which they have, that doesn't mean that everything in the Wall Street Journal
is garbage and it certainly doesn't mean that everything in every newspaper is garbage.
We should hold journalists accountable for the work that they do, but we shouldn't just throw them out.
We NEED them.
It feels like we're starting to live in a world where media critics are the news themselves.
People who attack expertise without any desire, let alone ability to replace expertise
and thus we get the high of feeling like we're better than the experts
without having to be experts on anything except for like drama and controversy.
I'm not saying that there isn't a problem in news media, that there's nothing to be fixed
But man am I sick of watching people ignore the tremendous amount of value that journalists provide
for our country and our world.
The destruction of expertise and all the terrible things that have come with it from feeling
personally ill informed, to electing a reality TV star president,
to continuing to deny the biggest crisis humanity has ever faced,
is all our fault. It is at the very least my fault.
I choose a preference for the op-eds and the hot takes.
I get confused about what news is. I look at what I read, and I think I can't trust the mainstream media anymore!
But I am CHOOSING to read the crap!
They're providing the crap which maybe they shouldn't but they have to because it's what people read.
And if they aren't getting it from mainstream media, they'll get it from the other guy.
Trustworthy journalism driven by expertise is out there
It's right where nobody's going to read it, buried deep down
on the front page
John, I'll see you on Tuesday